bonjour cette espèce françois mercier de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
les journalistes ont-ils dans le cadre
de leur travail l'obligation de porter
secours mais peuvent-ils être inquiété
par la justice s'ils ne le font pas les
journalistes n'ont pas d'obligations
particulières en tant que journaliste
pour porter secours aux policiers dans
le cadre de leur travail ce qui pourrait
leur être reprochée c'est une
non-assistance à personne en danger
toutefois la non-assistance à personne
en danger ll est soumise à des
conditions pour pouvoir intervenir
il faut que le journaliste casse assiste
à une celle qui est violente puisse
porter secours dans des conditions qui
soient pour lui sans risque ici on est
sur la base d'une simple photo qui
représente que ce qu'elle ne représente
c'est à dire un instantané à un moment
donné et elle ne donne pas des éléments
de contexte
alors on peut parfaitement comprendre ce
que peuvent ressentir les syndicats
policiers on voit dans cette image est
également les députés de la majorité qui
l'ont relayée en particulier sur twitter
députés de la majorité qui comme
l'indiqué ce sont eux qui sont à
l'origine de cette femme de loi sécurité
globale et en particulier son article 4
qui fait polémique et qui a donné lieu à
une manifestation que l'on connaît les
journalistes à ce que ça reviendrait pas
à rompre avec la neutralité
journalistique justement la déontologie
même du journalisme
quelles sont les limites de ce devoir de
neutralité en termes de droit ici pas la
neutralité elle s'apparente à de
l'information
ici je vois bien moi ce qui est reproché
ces deux là ne l'intervention sur une
altercation qui est en cours c'est à
dire qu'on voit des gens qui tabasse
littéralement un policier donc
plus on écoute dans la neutralité sur
l'information on est vraiment sur un
reproche qui est fait sur l'obligation
qui pourrait être d'agir pour mettre un
terme à une altercation c'est-à-dire
d'empêcher la réalisation d'un crime ou
d'un délit visant l'intégrité corporelle
donc tel qu'il est défini par le code
pénal mais je rappelle que dans la
définition que l'on a à l'article 223 6
du code pénal
on nous dit très précisément et qu' il
faut que l'intervention de la personne
qui vient apporter secours qui vient
empêcher la réalisation d'un délit
contre l'intégrité corporelle doit se
faire pour elle sans risque pour voiture
ici bon sur la photo qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir policier qui est tabassé par des
gens qui n'ont pas peur de s'en prendre
à lui donc c'est dire des gens qui sont
plutôt déterminé à s'en prendre à une
personne qui est équipé et on voit à
côté des journalistes qui sont eux
bon ils ont leur petit appareil photo
ils sont frères voilà on n'imagine pas
leur comment concrètement il pourrait
intervenir sans risques pour eux-mêmes
plusieurs manifestations ont eu lieu en
région à paris également ces dernières
semaines contre cette loi sécurité
globale le texte est ce qu'il risque de
porter atteinte à la liberté de la
presse qui est un principe fondamental
dans le conseil constitutionnel sera
t'il l'ultime arbitres pour ce texte
controversé ans et qui rayonne l'onu où
la commission européenne qui ont parlé
de ce cas très récemment
oui nécessairement le conseil
constitutionnel devrait intervenir en
bout de course parce que pour les îles
sans nécessairement cisi en particulier
par des et les parlementaires de de
l'opposition sur ce texte
le problème de cet article 24 on
comprend très bien pourquoi il a été
rédigé
c'est pour permettre la protection des
policiers en intervention est évident
qu'ils se fassent l'objet de lynchage
ensuite sur les réseaux sociaux que leur
identité soit divulguée et qu'ils soient
même mis en cause en revanche la
rédaction de textes
aujourd'hui est beaucoup trop flou parce
qu'elle essaye de combiner
maladroitement je pourrais dire et les
deux principes qui sont à la fois à
celui de la protection des forces de
l'ordre et puis de la liberté
d'information pour tout pour de cette
notion de malveillance qui est à mon
sens devrait être mieux défini beaucoup
en l'état il ya des doutes à avoir sur
le la rédaction même de l'article 4 qui
peut prêter à confusion a trop
d'interprétations et on voit bien qu'ils
cristallisent des des tensions extrêmes
et manuel m'apprendre donne une
interview à rémy buzine cet après midi
pour le média en ligne brut
un journaliste qui a subi des violences
policières on s'en souvient lors de
l'évacuation musclée à par les forces de
l'ordre du campement illégal des demies
grand place de la république à paris ces
derniers jours
emmanuel mâcon sera sûrement interrogé
sur ce thème qu'attendre du président de
la république sur cette thématique qu'il
arrive à apaiser les tensions je pense
que maintenant le l'objet de de
l'intervention du président de la
république c'est justement d'agir encore
président de la république c'est à dire
d'être le garant de l'unité nationale et
de gérer concilier un outil pour tout le
monde sait ça c'est le rôle que l'on
peut attendre de lui
ensuite concrètement comment ça va se
passer bon ce n'est pas forcément mon
rôle d'y répondre
voilà il imaginer ce qu'il pourrait être
10 c'est à dire de d'essayer de faire
des concessions particulier sur le sur
ce texte là qui est un texte s'il est
serti suscite une proposition de loi la
loi globale qu'elle émane du parlement
mais bon là la majorité a toute sa place
à présent à un public aussi la soutient
il y aura peut-être nécessairement de
des concessions à faire là ce niveau là
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
françois je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat